Republican Myra Flores now represents
the people in her District of 34. so
we're watching we're listening all of
this together I take it that
representative Cuellar is trying because
he says he is but he's not succeeding
what's going on with Democrats in Texas
right now particularly what's your
reaction to him
well we're sick and tired of this
Administration acting like this is a
humanitarian crisis is not happening and
we're really frustrated because this
isn't just a South Texas problem we need
all Sanctuary cities to step up and help
us with the influx of immigrants
Crossing illegally into our country we
have thousands of people coming in every
single day we have women and children
that have been through abuse that have
been through rape as well in this
dangerous Journey that the Bible
Administration continues to encourage
and this madness must stop we're asking
the buyer Administration to come to
South Texas to come and see what his
policies have done to us in South Texas
and what it's doing to our country as
well because it's not just the influx of
people coming in it's also fentanyl
coming into our country killing our our
youth the future of this country
representative Flores how and and Henry
Cuellar is a more conservative at times
Democrat but how are they even Lee
eating on this issue at all in any of
the states how are they Congress people
I mean you hear him talking there what
would you say to him
it's clear that the Biden Administration
doesn't care about South Texas doesn't
even care about what Henry Cuellar is
saying that should be assigned to Henry
cueller that he should not no longer be
supporting the Democrat Party that
doesn't even care to hear his cries and
his concerns that he has for his own
district and he should have stepped away
from the party that no longer represents
us in South Texas I don't know if you
can see some of this video but Cuellar
and other Democrats have said well you
know we want to want to leave things
open for people to come here legally we
are being overwhelmed they know that
there's no barrier there's nothing there
there is a legal process already there
is and if people wanted to follow it
they wouldn't just be the give-ups on
the other side of the river you
represent District 34. it has 85
majority Hispanic uh 85 percent majority
Hispanic population a place that was
Democrat for 100 years
until you flipped it read now new
polling shows that Biden and Democrats
are losing ground among Hispanic voters
is this issue playing any kind of a role
absolutely it is I immigrated to this
country I was blessed to come here to
United States legally but I will tell
you that the immigration is is broken we
do need to improve the legal process it
takes 15 to 20 years to be able to come
here to United States I was blessed to
have a father that was an American
citizen that was able to bring me
legally to United States but I believe
that we must secure the borders but we
also do need to improve the legal
process we need to hire more immigration
judges more Asylum officers so we can
process these claims because the
majority are unfortunate are not are not
uh real legitimate Asylum claims and we
need to be able to help those who
actually do have a legitimate Asylum
claim and I believe that by us focusing
on legal immigration and improving the
legal process we will bring down this
humanitarian crisis but again it's the
policies we can hire more border patrol
agents we can have you know a wall we
can have technology but if we don't
enforce the laws it nothing matters we
need to start enforcing the laws that we
already put in place that Congress put
in place we need to also put back the
policies that were working before this
administration because what's happening
in South Texas is because of the byte
Administration and it is time that we do
something about this in other states
like California New York step up I I
think about two groups of people in
Texas and I can only imagine your
constituents saying to you we're
spending taxpayer money billions of
dollars now in Texas to do what the
federal government refuses to do to make
sure that those border patrol agents
Texas DPS and others are ready there the
National Guard members who went out with
us at 1 30 in the morning I mean all of
that has to be paid for
I can't imagine people want their tax
dollars paid that spent that way but
they I I can't imagine what would happen
if it weren't spent that way
exactly where you were years using
millions and millions of local resources
we are at Max Capacity we can handle
this anymore the people of bronville for
example are struggling to pay their
light bill their light bill just tripled
their light bill went from 300 to 900
you're struggling to pay their utility
bills their groceries all my district
right now is struggling but yet we're
focused on the humanitarian crisis and
not able to help the American people the
people that elected us to be in the
position that we're in and that is why
it's so important for us to secure the
border for us to be able to focus on the
districts that we represent these are
the people that elected us and it is
time that we put them first
there you go and that was my second
Point how unfair is it to the people
like yourself and others who've come
here illegally have to put people first
who are willing to follow our laws uh
representative Meyer Flores I know you
are up against uh another competition
this November good luck to you and thank
you for joining us
thank you God bless you God bless you
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights